Film Courage: Have you ever thought of stopping?
Have you said to yourself ‘There are easier
ways to spend my life.’
Kelli McNeil, Writer, Actress and Voice Over
Artist: All the time.
I mean I’ve carved out a career for myself
as a marketing and creative professional,
copywriting and art directing (things like
that).
If I really gave myself to that maybe I could
be very successful but I feel like there would
be this hole inside of me that would just
be devoid.
I think that maybe I’m not very smart.
Maybe I should have given up a long time ago
because I keep putting myself through this
and trying and keep going but I think that’s
part of the challenge that a lot of writers
face is the self-doubt and the imposter syndrome
and especially as a woman and trying to break
through in this industry it’s very hard.
Yeah…you grapple with that all the time
and writing by nature is a very solitary activity.
It’s very easy to want to throw in the towel
and that’s why it’s so important to celebrate
those little victories, just one little thing,
one connection, one interview, one chance
encounter could change your world.
Film Courage: But by naming the imposter syndrome
and sort of calling it out, does that take
away its power a little bit?
Kelli: You have to be aware of it when it’s
happening.
There are times and I think this comes with
age and maturity as well.
Certainly I am more grounded now in my 30’s
then I was in my 20’s.
I’m able to own my mistakes more readily.
I’m able to objectively look at myself and
separate the part of me that needs approval
to the part of me that is trying to create
something as well.
If I can give myself enough space to fail,
then I can help overcome that imposter syndrome
but it’s not an easy thing to do.
I know a lot of people grapple with it.
Film Courage: When you’re in that space
of writing about some character that is so
real, it’s speaking to you, it’s kind
of scary, it might be a little edgy, that
sounds like it’s not being an imposter by
any means?
Kelli: That’s such a rare state of enlightenment
that…like I said it’s almost like getting
a runner’s high.
It doesn’t happen all the time but it is
magic when it does.
Question: How many times have you quit writing?